well the first goal has been achieved
and knowing what the vision is and where
you want to go I think that if we're
going to see more action we need to have
a better alignment between the
investment community from both the
private and public sector as well as
large multinationals and small and
medium enterprises I'm from PepsiCo
originally from beautiful cape town now
living in New York and we certainly see
the opportunities to move into an action
phase across many African countries
particularly when you've got a receptive
government when you've got investors and
developers a people want you to work
with you I where is the clear set of
products and we hope that before long
we'll have some exciting responses to
share what we doing across Africa by the
2012 we're meeting